it is the next chapter in Apple's story
and here it is the original Apple watch
was revealed many years ago in 2014 and
it not only kick-started the Smartwatch
Market but it completely revolutionized
the entire watch industry and now we
have the Apple watch Ultra which is
honestly the best Apple product of 2022
and I'm gonna explain why in this video
from both a marketing psychology
perspective as well as my own personal
experience with it over the past couple
of months but don't take my word for it
you the people actually voted it in as
the Supreme winner yes nine to five Mac
ran a bracketed tournament on Twitter
using the poll function allowing the
people to vote for the best Apple
product of 2022 and of course the Apple
watch Ultra came out on top but before I
get into explaining precisely why it's
so special compared to the other
products Apple released this this year I
want to quickly run through some of the
losers because there's actually a really
clear pattern to why they ended up being
losing products starting from the top
it's pretty obvious why the M2 iPad Pro
was voted out so quickly it's got the
same exact design with only a chip swap
being the big difference and it's the
smallest iPad Pro update in history and
really quite disappointing then we have
the iPad Air 5 which lost for basically
the same reasons the same design also
just a chip swap and to be honest a lot
of the other losers that were voted out
in the first round loss for essentially
the same reasons now I will say that the
Mac Studio could have easily gotten
further in the bracket because it truly
is a very special Mac in terms of design
and value but it was up against the
iPhone 14 pro so it was destined to lose
there the M2 MacBook Air was honestly a
great product this year due to the new
design but of course it was plagued by
by the SSD chip swap issues and it was
also up against the 14 pro now the
airpods Pro 2 are definitely great in
terms of the sound quality and feature
set but honestly the design didn't
change one bit which led to a loss
against the Apple watch Ultra and then
finally the ultra squeezed out a win
against the iPhone 14 pro which is
definitely the best iPhone ever
especially thanks to the huge camera
improvements and removal of the notch
but once again the design has barely
changed and that leaves us with the
ultra as the winner and if it wasn't
already obvious why it won if you look
at the trends throughout the entire
tournament it's got to do with refresh
design and the feature set and honestly
I totally agreed with the results of
this tournament before I even saw it
with the ultra being the winner for my
own personal reasons and experience that
I'm gonna get into in just a minute but
first let me get into the marketing
psychology of why the ultra is so
special that it ended up with a win for
2022 and it all started many years ago
with the original Apple watch changing
the entire watch industry and quickly
becoming the best selling watch in the
world and now as far as the regular
Apple watch models we're now on the
series 8 which is kind of hard to
believe because if you look at it and
compare it to how the original Apple
watch looked they're more similar than
they are different sure this series 8 is
a lot thinner than it was before and
sure the display is now larger curved
and edge to edge but it generally looks
like the same watch and as far as the
feature set Apple has been slowly
upgrading the internals like the
bluetooth specs chips and sensors adding
a little bit more over the years but in
general it's kind of hard to believe
that Apple was able to get away with so
many updates throughout the years
considering the small number of
improvements and upgrades the folks over
at Apple really are marketing Kings
convincing more and more people to buy a
slightly better Apple watch year after
year after year so after almost a decade
of basically the same old watch being
sold over and over again we have the
Apple watch Ultra the first redesign
actually worthy of being called a
redesign the general shape has finally
changed with an airpods max style
protrusion which allows for a totally
unique shape and extra internal space
for battery life a brand new Crown guard
on the side to protect a totally new
larger and bulkier Crown as well as an
easier to press side button and even a
brand new additional action button on
the other side the Finish comes in a
natural titanium that isn't painted at
all what you see on the outside is the
actual color of the metal itself so the
Finish can't get scratched off and for
the first time ever we have a flat
display glass panel which is completely
protected sitting behind a titanium
metal ring and a newly redesigned
speaker that's much louder than before
which also includes the new siren
feature this right here is what I call
an Apple Watch redesign if you see this
on somebody's wrist you know it's the
new Ultra and you just couldn't say the
same for any other Apple watch update in
the past except for the series 5 which
of course added the always-on display
but it's not just the design that's
special because Apple packed it to the
brim with new features specs and sensors
that simply aren't possible on previous
watch models so unlike almost every
other Apple product that came out this
year that was mostly a refresh version
of a previous design the Apple watch
Ultra is the one that stands out the
most because this design is completely
different on so many levels and in terms
of value eight hundred dollars for what
you get is honestly so worth it
considering the fact that it comes with
a titanium Metal finish for the same
base price while simply upgrading to
stainless steel on the regular series 8
brings it up to around the same price
anyway so in terms of marketing
psychology when the world is used to
getting the same old Apple watch with
minor changes every year for almost a
decade a product like the Apple watch
Ultra delivered such a huge shock to the
entire industry that people couldn't
help themselves but to love it both for
the new design and the actual feature
set as well the ultra basically proves
that Apple isn't done innovating and
they're not done pushing the rest of the
industry forward and that's what really
makes it special compared here to all of
the other Apple products this year and
those reasons are honestly why I
personally upgraded to the ultra it's
just so special and unique that I
actually wanted to wear an Apple Watch
For the First Time In many years even
though I've been an Apple fan for as
long as I remember so with all of that
out of the way let me explain my own
personal experience with the ultra and
why I like it so much to be completely
honest I'm the most casual user out
there that barely put this watch through
its paces and Barely Used any of the
hardcore features that this watch offers
but I didn't buy it for that I bought it
for three reasons starting with the
unique design which I think looks
industrial and I absolutely love that
about it I love that it's thick and
bulky I love that extra Crown guard the
second reason is the display that's
super bright when you're outside and the
Peace of Mind knowing that the sapphire
crystal is essentially scratch proof and
it's crack resistant because the metal
outer ring protects it and I seriously
love the night mode which you can turn
on by spinning the crown I use it almost
exclusively and the final reason is the
battery life holy moly it's absolutely
insane over the past couple of months
that's been the number one thing that
has blown me away because I only have to
charge it every three days yes every
three days I can literally come home and
leave it on my countertop for two days
in a row without having to worry about
charging it it's just been a dream
compared to previous models that must be
charged every night that by itself makes
this a completely different experience
but all in all is the unique design that
made me cave in and buy one and that is
why I think it gets the product of the
Year award so if you completely disagree
with me in my thoughts on this video let
me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed it click that
Circle about to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out one of
those two right there thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]